hi guys sci-fi recapped here today I am
going to explain the film called The
Traveler spoilers ahead watch out and
stay safe the movie opens up with two
kids Jody and Brandon throwing water
balloons at the nearby pedestrians they
have been best friends since long and
often like doing mischievous things
unfortunately while they are having fun
one of their neighbors Mrs gunson
catches them she secretly records their
video and chastises them for being a
menace to society after this Mrs gunson
takes them to Jody's mom June and shows
the video to her here it is clear that
the kids are tired of Mrs gunson as she
always interrupts their fun even June
doesn't like her Mrs gunson gives the
example of a nearby kid named Jonathan
who used to steal from the neighbors one
day he was caught and sentenced to 200
hours of community service Mrs gunson
reveals that Jonathan is still
struggling from the punishment and his
whole life has been turned upside down
after the speech Mrs gunson leaves with
Brandon she now wants to go to his house
and complain to his parents meanwhile
Jane takes Jody inside the room and
chastises her for always causing trouble
the teenager tries to explain that
having fun is not a crime but Jane makes
it clear that if she does it again she
will never be allowed to go outside from
their conversation it is evident that
Jane is always troubled because of her
daughter she is a single mother who
works multiple shifts to support the
family but Jody always keeps messing
with her schedule this time Jane grounds
her daughter for a week warning her to
stay inside the house after she leaves
however Jody immediately calls her best
friend and the two start playing video
games Jonathan who is busy cleaning the
area just then everyone stops at the
same time as if an external force is
controlling them they completely freeze
not even a single person moves an inch
then a mysterious guy with blue skin
approaches Jonathan from behind and zaps
him with his hands following this the
scene cuts to Jody and Brandon who are
still playing video games one thing
leads to another and they start fighting
inside the room Unfortunately they end
up destroying the television and at the
same time Jane enters Furious she sends
Brandon away and then starts scolding
her daughter for being irresponsible and
Reckless first she invited a friend when
she was grounded and then she broke the
TV surprisingly the teenager responds
that it was just a TV she still does not
want to take responsibility for her
actions hearing this Jane becomes upset
and she starts thinking if Jody cares
about her at all she claims that her
years are being taken away from her
because she has to work extremely hard
sometimes she wonders if she should
continue living in the next scene Jody
heads downstairs where she is approached
by a scared old man he is none other
than Jonathan who has aged rapidly after
being Zapped by The Stranger Jonathan
tries to explain the entire ordeal to
Jody however she does not recognize him
so to make her understand he brings out
a large box that was left by the
stranger it has a card on it that says
take and all take from you Jody is
confused by the strange device but
before she could inquire about it
Jonathan runs away after a while Jody
decides to take the box home to examine
it however before she can carry it the
cunning Mrs gunson spots her she assumes
that the teenager has stolen the device
so she takes it for herself Jody tries
to claim that an old man gifted it to
her but to no avail after a while Mrs
gunson hides the strange box in her
locker and leaves Jody watches this from
nearby and at an opportune moment she
goes to the locker and opens it using
her hair clip she then brings out the
box and carries it to her home there she
opens it and finds a strange device
inside curious she presses it and
surprisingly the world around her
freezes but Jody doesn't realize this
and when she presses the button again
everything returns back to normal just
then her mom enters the room and asks
where she got the device from Jody tries
to claim that a friend of hers gifted it
to her but Jane assumes that her
daughter has again started stealing so
she snatches the device and attempts to
throw it away but right then Jody
inadvertently presses the button because
of this everything freezes including her
mother this shocks Jody for a while but
soon she starts having fun with it at
first she tricks Jane by freezing her
and hiding the Box away then she gets
out of her house despite being grounded
and meets Brandon who is also Frozen in
time he is holding his phone on one hand
and ice cream on the other Jody switches
them and when she unfreezes the time
Brandon accidentally puts the ice cream
in his ears shocked he asks her how she
did it and Jody finally reveals about
the strange device after this the two
press the button together and decide to
have some fun downstairs they see
several people stuck in time and start
messing them up one by one first they
replace a woman's sandwich with a flower
then they put an egg beneath another
woman's feet they even mess up a
gardener by pointing the direction of
his water hose right at him when they
press the button and unfreeze everything
chaos unfolds all the people are left
enraged but they have no clue how it
happened following this the kids decide
to go house to house and steal food they
appear to be having the time of their
lives they can annoy people eat all that
they want and even stay deal money
without having to face any repercussions
however little did they know that
everything comes at a price someone is
coming to teach them a lesson in the
next scene as Brandon and Jody are
chatting in their room they hear a
sudden noise coming from outside this
startles them as the world is supposed
to be in freeze mode they slowly go
outside to inspect and learn that Mrs
gunson's Locker has been broken by
someone suddenly the two hears some
footsteps approaching them and become
terrified so Brandon and Jody pretend as
if they are Frozen as well after a few
seconds the mysterious Blue Man
approaches them he inspects the two
teenagers thoroughly and despite his
best efforts to intimidate them they
don't budge this convinces him that
Brandon and Jody are not suspicious so
he leaves after a while as the teenagers
are contemplating their next move they
hear Mrs gunson screaming from her room
terrified they rush to inspect and from
the window they see the Blue Man zapping
Mrs gunson with a strange blue current
the latter asks why he is doing all this
and the Man shows her the same card
which says take and I'll take from you
here it is revealed that Mrs gunson is
being punished for always stealing from
her neighbors although she acts tough on
the kids and reprimands them for having
fun she herself is a hardcore thief the
blue man found out about this and Zapped
a part of her face turning her into an
old woman unfortunately once he is done
he notices the kids peeking through the
window and goes after them Jody and
Brandon quickly Rush upstairs and lock
themselves in a room they try to make
sense of the situation and this is when
Jody realizes that the old man who
approached her earlier was actually
Jonathan he was also punished for being
a bad influence to society now the blue
man is probably after Jody because she
stole the box from him terrified she
plans to return it immediately hoping
the man will forgive her the two then
leave the Box downstairs and wait for
the man to retrieve it however the plan
doesn't work as despite the man getting
his box back he still doesn't stop
pursuing the children after a small
Chase he eventually Corners them in a
room and proceeds to zap Brandon but
right then Jody stops him she pleads
with the blue man to leave her best
friend alone claiming that he has
nothing to do with it it was she who
stole the box and used it for her
pleasure if there is someone who needs
to be punished it is her hearing this
the Blue Man leaves Brandon and goes
after her he is about to turn her into
an old woman but this time Brandon stops
him he requests the man to leave them
alone in exchange they are willing to
write all their wrongs Jody asks if it
is because of all the pranks they have
played on their neighbor but the man
says no instead he points towards Jane
seeing this Jody finally realizes that
the man is after her because of how she
is treating her mother she always
disrespects her and causes her to cry
Jane is trying her best to give them a
good life but Jody being a brat never
acknowledges her efforts realizing this
Jody promises to be a good daughter from
now on and the blue man finally agrees
before leaving however he zaps Jody's
hands and turns it old giving her a
small demo of what will happen if she
disobeys him again in the final scene
the two teenagers have stopped pranking
others they now try their best to help
help their family and anyone who is in
need they have also collected enough
money to buy a new television for Jane
the movie ends as Jody checks her
wrinkly hand and expresses gratitude
towards the blue man for changing her
life subscribe and hit that like button
to help our Channel grow turn the
notifications on so you won't miss any
of our new videos thanks for watching
[Music]